in the middle of May I got email from a
guy whose screen name was cold guy he
told me that the angry video game nerd
was going to make a live appearance at a
store called digital press he was
wondering if you wanted me to come on
down and actually meet him James and I
talked about meeting up for a while I
looked like this was a pretty good
opportunity so I emailed him and asked
if it was cool and he was like yeah sure
come on down I called him up to go over
the details and at the very end I asked
him the question if you would consider
making another video like a final battle
something choreographed has special
effects and all that good stuff now this
guy's already doing me a huge favor so
if he just said no he's too busy or he
didn't want to do it I would just agree
right there and the idea would die but
luckily he said yes so we drove eight
hours down to Pennsylvania stopped at
his house and filmed the video so
contrary to what you might believe the
final battle was actually filmed one day
before the digital press fight before we
left I wrote out a script of the final
battle to give an idea exactly what we
would do I emailed it to James the day
after I wrote it he read it 10 minutes
before we thought I'm thinking of me I
want the first punch because then it's
almost like then when you like I'm about
to punch it it's almost like like we're
so ready for it inside I'm like I'm
really standing at the door waiting for
a you show up baby when you finally do
ring the doorbell with you can you open
up yeah she'll be about to punch you and
they touch me sorrowful Emily you know
it just starts being up outside I
imagine that behind you is just like
cartoon like trees and not like those
and it's not like it's is really heavy
look you comes on members module so
basically the background is gonna look
like care alot but we could build that
up in the firt in that whatever video
comes before like alright I'm coming
down to you and it taking like 20 hours
to drive there but when I come there you
be ready angry nerd you be ready because
I will come there at any time and that's
really
why'd you come out of the Wardrobe be
wearing and at the end of the Super
Mario 3 Vega super decked out yes it's
big I have a lot of stuff still sorry
I've never done this before never
attached a Power Pad to someone's back
talk about it yeah I guess like the
martial arts Oh at some part you got to
do like you know fireballs yeah we're
gonna hang this on your campus okay yeah
how about uh yeah well there it is the
Nostalgia Critic victory over the game
nerd he hangs his own suit on his screen
is or the canopy to that the Angry Video
Game Nerd sixes Dino
I didn't open on me I go there no we're
gonna use like glass yeah they were
selling those like a really funny joke
just like yeah no I'm gonna tell you how
the videos gonna go okay I'm gonna win
this is gonna be she's all a bitch I
wasn't back I do it I do like that stamp
you're on that ever happened like you'd
have it the wrong way
oh yeah what if you don't realize you
have one of Darth Maul's double
lightsabers interaction we brought in
Torrington worried that maybe he gets my
play that's having just a quickie wait
try it try it see if you can do it we
always know and the shade of Jedi's just
know like where I'm supposed to hold it
there's there's a giant this side up
arrow on the side of it has anybody ever
parodied that I don't think so nobody's
ever done that you know this baseball
still on stuff family god I never had
one actually went into their home yeah
that's a good idea yeah
historic moment getting dressed in the
house of the very surreal oh shit no I
just ruin this whole thing this might be
trouble cuz I actually don't know how to
tie a tie so I just do it once and I
just keep it up what do you want me to
turn the camera off now it is this is
pretty ambitious very embarrassing
I see if they not don't type you know
how to tie a tie you know what I don't
do you don't have a time time oh you
know it um kind not really there's four
guys in this house nobody knows that tie
a tie
well you don't I know like now he's
dressing he's never making it anywhere
this is never gonna be sure oh I'm gonna
make sure this gets in there you know I
don't have a clue
this whole epic battle you know all to a
halt because of a fucking tie wait what
oh no wait
oh uh no don't touch me
all right Doug do you want to explain
what happened uh I'm a douche and I
can't tie a tie and this place was like
four guys none of us know how to tie a
tie so we had to give James his wife to
it did she do a good job
she'd been afraid this night this is
about the closest we're gonna get yeah
what's good enough on camera yeah I
think that's what we're going for it
said it's pretty embarrassing the hell
mom I don't know and this is going up on
the website isn't it oh you did not buy
anything to say yeah we can make stuff
up as we're going like that I have so
much stuff down everyone we could like
it I go use this and you know cause like
we're gonna we the box is the ID the
boxes I think is kind of fun the who
late who has boxes later on the fall and
stuff yeah
as it is it's like a parody like that's
the whole point you know it's funny
because there's always boxes all the
time um we're actually doing the boxes
in the Batman video which we're doing on
like Sunday Monday okay
I'm wondering if it would be too
redundant to do the boxes or that which
is Furler you know because there's going
to be a gap in between yeah it's gotta
be spaced in between I think that would
be fine cuz it's like because at first
people see the box it's like all the
traditional video game they're boxes you
know and then I finally read friend who
keeps boxes and hallway looking piles of
boxes around honestly this is the pile
of boxes which this schmuck is gonna
jump into yeah you're gonna do it action
goodbye ending
awesome that's pretty good
do it to like when maybe when you Europe
sir like like water they're always boxes
why do you have boxes all the time and
I'll just be like don't talk about the
boxes I am talking I like my boxes oh
don't you talk about my boxes I like
boxes and so we always have these
colorful you know insulted so let me go
where'd we throw the man each other ciao
helping transvestite b5 oh fuck you ass
blower turn burglar robble robble be the
box there we can end like two lines that
I love mine improvising than ceiling
which is yelling back with a box classic
that's yeah that's pretty much the whole
fight right there
you
yeah yeah that's right
real lights a bit you dizzy